we are right on on the hinge we're right
on the edge of a national divorce now i
have a contrarian view on this which is
i actually think the sooner we built the
build the parallel economy and we have
these other mediums i actually think it
de-escalates
the chance for a national divorce i
think it's the exact opposite
yeah i like that actually it's kind of
like all right you do you we do us like
maybe we can have like a five-year
cooling off period before we actually
sign the divorce papers right
and i i don't think i think the more
that we live under their tyranny you're
going to see real radicalism rise up
that i hate and you hate right where
people are starting to talk about things
that i don't i don't want the country to
break up i think it's an awful thing
it's my home it's your home i don't want
to have to show a passport when i go to
lax it's like i want that to be my
fellow countrymen
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of the charlie kirk show the
founder of turning point usa and the
author of the maga doctrine the only
ideas that will win the future
charlie kirkhold friend welcome back to
the reuben report
dave you're a good friend honored to be
here thank you for having me we've done
this a couple times and i thought how
can i approach this interview in a way
that's a little different than uh what
we've done before so i thought we'd
start off give me your top 10
reasons you love joe biden
top 10 reasons i love joe biden that's
um
you know i will say he's actually made
me prioritize things in life that matter
not to say politics don't matter yeah
but it's been such a dumpster fire you
have to kind of look outside of all the
madness
and you're like okay what really matters
in life right like what exactly gives
you purpose and meaning because
obviously
the things that
you know we used to i used to look at
the presidency as something i revere and
i guess i still do and i love my country
but he's been so awful it's like okay
there's a couple things i can control in
my life like family and relationships
friendships uh career and i'm going to
focus on those things and it's kind of
the one of the few things i want to
thank joe biden for is he has reinforced
at least for me things that i control
and things i cannot control
unfortunately i can't control the
southern border i can talk about it it's
wide open and it's a total disaster but
uh besides that i'm not i'm not sure uh
sure what else i would put on that list
dave
i thought maybe you could come up with
three i thought maybe there were going
to be three but i'll i'll accept that
but for a guy like you yeah go ahead
well i mean i guess if you want to kind
of do the whole like
you know ha glass half full thing and
the perpetual optimus thing and the best
thing about being surrounded is you can
shoot in any direction thing
which is
basically look i do think that
there's been unintended consequences of
what this regime has been trying to
implement which is the rise of the
citizen and
try who you were gonna get there that
was one of the three i had in there
right and like the the homeschooling
revolution and people really caring
about their country again
and there is a window there's an
opportunity there's a chance there's a
sliver i i don't think it's by any
chance certain that this backfires on
them so dramatically that it could be a
political realignment the likes of which
our generation
we haven't seen in 30 or 40 years
do you believe in the machine enough to
believe that something like that could
happen because that's the direction i
thought you were going to go because
it's like everything is so bad
everything is so upside down even for
guys like us who expected this thing to
be bad it's worse than most of us could
have imagined but do you think the
machine will allow like just in the last
couple days watching the narrative on
kovid shift like
do you think it'll allow
what should happen to happen that the
voice of the people will actually be
heard
well thankfully between the media and
the whole thing that's what i'm talking
about yeah well no for sure of course
yeah thankfully critical parts of the
machine are falling apart which gives me
hope i mean cnn is basically a democrat
super pac that no one watches
facebook is cratering which is really
really interesting to see rumble who
which you and i really care about is
ascending so there are certain trends
right now that kind of go into maybe the
machine isn't as strong as it once was
americans trust in government as an
all-time low americans trust in
corporations are at all-time low you're
starting to see people care more about
local than national trends which is
really really important so i think that
i think the machine is way weaker than
it was even a year ago and let alone
five years ago i think that there is
kind of like a natural law component to
this where if you try to build a
multi-trillion dollar
oligarchy or oligopoly oligopoly i
should say it prob the laws of gravity
are probably going to push back against
you at some point there will be leaks in
dissension civil war fracturing and
you're seeing a lot of that not just
within the democrat party but within a
lot of the super superstructures that
you and i believe the actual power
is vested in so look i could have a
cynical take where i'm like you know
what these people always have power the
infrastructure is impenetrable but i'm
not so sure of that i think i think that
there is a revival to challenge all
these institutions and dave you've
played a really important part in this
which is those of us that love freedom
and love the constitution is the
greatest political document ever we're
building our own infrastructure we're
building our own machine
and that's been a really exciting trend
i think the regime is really surprised
by it i think they're shocked quite
honestly that we've been able to kind of
stand up
a youtube competitor a payment
processing competitor a patreon
competitor like locals
so quickly you're starting to see a
higher education competitor of
university of austin and all of a sudden
this kind of
this
this
monopoly they had on these certain goods
and services and credentialing
institutions is being challenged in a
very serious way
but they're still they're still way more
powerful than us there's no doubt
but i'm optimistic that there might be
some legitimate fault lines that are
going to materialize in in their demise
that would be a slightly better great
reset than the great reset that they've
been telling us about but i'm curious
for you
look i know you i know you off camera
too at this point but i don't know that
i've ever fully asked you this before
like you know you were so obviously a
close uh associate and and through
turning point in the trump's campaign
and you wrote the book the mega doctrine
the whole thing to go from that and you
know i would go to turning point the
night that i met trump at mar-a-lago we
were at dinner that very night there and
it was after an event you put together
and all that stuff and i say that
because you were so associated with that
now he's not empowered i just wonder for
you personally
like what did the last year show i'm not
talking about the political part of my
guy's not empowering anymore but just
like the other you were part of
something that was fun and cool at least
from our perspective and now you ain't
in it or you know the thing exists but
like it's not in power anymore so like
what is that just personally for you
like
well first it was really demoralizing
not from like an access standpoint or
like the fact you could call the
president like whatever it was just kind
of demoralizing for the country right i
mean especially the month of january
we're like okay
you know at new year's i remember
thinking all right okay biden's gonna be
president at the very least we can win
these senate races in georgia you know
we can have a check in balance
separation
and then january 5th happened like okay
we lost that and then january 6 happened
which was a catastrophe right uh for a
variety of different reasons and so it
was a demoralizing couple weeks in 2021
and our team at turning point usa which
has always been educationally focused
and our team at the charlie kirk show
which has obviously been very aligned
with the trump doctrine and his
worldview
what do we stand for and we really went
to work you know i traveled 330 days uh
in the year of 2021 and went to campuses
and churches and
we didn't talk a lot about trump
honestly we didn't talk about biden
either more than anything else we talked
about what it meant to be an american
and what we stood for and why we stood
for it and it was definitely this moment
where
i also had to kind of reintroduce myself
to a lot of people that just kind of
knew me as oh you're the guy that
defends trump right and it was i think
very well received in a lot of different
ways and i also think it forced
our team and our show to go a level
deeper i spent more time in 2021 of
reading deep books and spending time in
very complex philosophy and really
challenging my ideas and why i believe
it and where does it come from because
it wasn't just kind of like okay the
left is out of their mind we have to
defend the president we have because
he's doing a really good job and you can
kind of get really used to that right um
but then all of a sudden when he's
displaced from power there's a lot of
people that are saying okay do we want
to go back to like the liz cheney kind
of way of doing things or why do we want
you know borders to be controlled and so
you have to kind of come come from that
with an approach that is philosophically
based and rooted in a natural rights
doctrine and also in timeless ideas
while also respecting the fruits of the
enlightenment all these really important
things
and so i think that we've been i think
we're better because of it honestly i
think our show's more interesting i
think our organization is stronger i
think we're reaching more people
and you know i'm not to say not to say
that i'm thankful i mean the country's
in horrible shape but i think we i think
we were able to use what was an
adversarial situation or a set of
circumstances to our advantage
do you think that they think
that they're doing good i mean this is a
little bit of the road to hell kind of
situation like do you think i mean i
don't know if biden's in charge at this
point which if you want to comment on
that feel free but like
when they all put their heads on the
pillow when saki lays down at night
biden
the rest of them the surgeon general all
of these people that are associated with
this thing fauci all of them do you
really think they're looking at the
information looking at what's going on
here supply chain inflation afghanistan
etc and going boy we really are doing a
great job
man you ask good questions i got to tell
you i ask questions too every day and
it's a great question because i get this
all the time and people say what is the
motive right how do they how do they
judge success like what what is the what
does the white board look like
in
you know the outer room of the oval
right like are we going towards the
mission accomplished or are we getting
further away from it
and this is a hard thing for some people
on the center right or people that love
the constitution to admit it's not hard
for me to admit because i kind of
understand the left really well
i think
they're right on schedule for what they
want and i really do believe that they
want to be
a
willing participant in the world
economic forum great reset you mentioned
it you know a little bit sarcastically
earlier but you and i both know this is
a very real agenda which is it's legit i
just did an hour with glenn beck on it
yeah and and it's i think that in order
to get there you have to first make
america no longer a superpower and that
doesn't mean you have to kill everybody
right i mean i think there's some
extremes people can take towards
describing this but you definitely have
to destroy our currency you have to
deteriorate our sovereignty you have to
erode the national will and then also
you have to create mass uncertainty as
what as to what it means to be an
american
and the person that's probably done the
best job of this is nicole hannah jones
from the 1619 project it's something we
talk about every single day at turning
point usa which if you can't tell an
agreed upon american story then you just
don't have a country i mean it's such
polar opposites where you and i would
look at the american founding as a
heroic breakthrough of the human story
where nicole hannah jones look looks at
it as a regressive moment in the human
story
there really isn't much in common from
that point forward right when you can't
agree on the federalist papers the
declaration the constitution the bill of
rights
and so i believe that the people in
charge from ron claim to biden they
might have their own little kind of
wrinkles of where they think the country
should go but it's definitely in a place
where they want to de-emphasize
america's role in the world they want to
weaken america and they think the world
will be better because of it this is the
most important thing though is that i
mean in the beginning of aristotle's
ethics there's this incredible line that
is hotly debated which is all human
action points towards some good now you
take out the mentally and clinically
insane from that but really what he's
getting at is that
more evil has been done under people
believing that they're doing good than
anything else
you you take joseph stalin he actually
thought he was bettering humanity or
bettering himself or whatever very few
people are actually yes i'm doing what
is wrong and i'm going to keep on doing
it it's a very rare thing and i think
that these people in charge no i don't
think biden's in charge i think he's a
puppet be for all these other masters i
actually don't think very much about
biden um i actually really haven't
engaged much in kind of the mental
decline kind of meme verse if you will i
think it's a little overdone we all kind
of know he's not there i'm more
interested in the people behind him and
the and the the reason they're doing all
this but yes i think that from the
treasury secretary janet yellen to
mayorkis to the educational secretary to
all of them i think that
they believe that they are all
doing what a good comrade should do
to try and usher in a globalist type
project and the american superpower
status of a strong economy being energy
independent a sound currency and a
national story that we all agree on
those are things that are right at the
heart of their agenda
do you think that
conservatives whatever this new wide
tent thing is at this point this
anti-woke coalition and we'll see how
how tightly it can hold do you think we
just need a better story do you think
the story of just telling the american
history say the way we've seen it or the
way that you and i have talked about it
for a long time uh that maybe that isn't
enough just going back to say reagan
talking points as as good and decent as
they are like do we need a new story a
new narrative to craft to capture young
people i mean obviously that's what you
guys are trying to do at turning point
but is is just saying freedom and
individual rights and capitalism is it
not enough that there has to be
something else behind that too
it's not enough but it will be enough
this year which worries me
it will be enough to take back power for
republicans and defeat the woke just to
run against the woke they're so
unpopular they're so awful at governing
and that's the thing dave is that not
only do they have bad ideas they're
actually bad at executing their bad
ideas i mean it's like the worst
possible thank god you know to kind of
combinate well no that that's the thing
where i had i got in this debate the
other day and someone says charlie we
need more technology in government so
they can be more efficient i'm like you
know i'm actually really glad
that they're slow
yeah i'm really glad that they take
arbor day off because if they didn't
then they'd be like google which we know
how harmful they can be which we'll get
into the whole corporate side of this
but i'm worried because i'm afraid that
there's going to be
kind of a
false stimulus effect to the
conservative movement like all we have
to do is run against the woke we take
back every chamber of power like the
glenn younkin thing right where i'm
afraid that we're going to need a lot
more i'll give you an example of what a
lot more looks like which i think
conservatives need to think very deeply
about a national recovery program i
think that this country has been so
severely damaged by unelected
bureaucrats especially young people most
suicidal drug addicted alcohol addicted
most anxious depressed medicated
generation in history that i think there
needs to be an intergenerational apology
to try to get this generation back on
track and i'm not saying massive
government programs or some sort of
climate core like aoc wants but i think
we should try to make it easier to try
to have conservatizing events and the
three conservatizing events if you will
just accept the term is to own property
to get married and have kids and
hopefully a nice fourth one is have a
job that means something to you right
that isn't like a minimum wage job or
some sort of woke social media manager
for goldman sachs or whatever right
those four things are harder than ever
for this generation to grab onto
and i think that we need to have
pro-market-based conversations outside
of just kind of the immediate muscle
memory of the dogma of the kind of
ghosts of rogan reagan past and say how
do we make it easier for a 28 year old
that's a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
that was locked down for a couple years
right is really demoralized might be on
an unnecessary regimen of
antidepressants how to make it easier
for them to break through and buy quote
unquote equity in the american project
right because that actually is a really
good thing for the country people don't
burn down wendy's if they have a
mortgage
when you're renting all the time you
become a per you become a perfect
population that could be captured by
these kind of woke socialist
revolutionaries and so no i don't think
it's just enough to kind of have the
slogans i think we need to think
creatively about these things and
i think we also need to know why we
believe in what we believe it the
constitution needs to be our north star
it is the greatest political document
ever we nothing we should do should
violate the four basic tenets of the
constitution
separation of powers consent to the
governed independent judiciary um and
balance of power basically those are
that's the core basis of the us
constitution but with that being said
though dave i think that we have
portions of the american population that
have been so set back by the lockdowns
and government interference that if we
don't come up with something more robust
or exciting
we're going to be looking at a potential
political population that will entertain
seriously radical ideas right i mean how
much worse it could be if we don't do
something to heal some of these wounds
you accidentally said ghosts of rogan
pass i know that i will get to that
you're right that will be a heck that
will be a hell of a segue we're going to
slide into when we talk about big tech
in just a little bit but you said
something interesting there about the
intergenerational version of this and
i've been thinking about this a lot that
so many of the people that are in power
right now or at least appear to be in
power say joe biden
say nancy pelosi
said you know any of these people really
any of them you can dianne feinstein who
everyone knows is almost incapacitated
at this point just the amount of of
uh you know they're not i guess they're
upper end boomers but they're also the
last of the great generations something
like that but these people that are in
their say mid 70s and up that are still
clinging to power nancy pelosi with that
ridiculous re-election video from two
weeks ago and it's like lady you're 81
go be a grandma like enough do you think
there's something what do you think that
is psychologically maybe about that
generation that they can't let go
because that does seem to be a big
problem here and i've seen in just the
last couple weeks that suddenly gen x
i'm 45 right in the middle of gen x like
my generation you're you're a little
younger than me so you're not you're gen
y is that fair to say
i'm uh i'm millennial yeah
you're a millennial no offense uh but
that that the
35 right but the 35 36 to say 54 year
olds we just haven't had our chance yet
because for some reason those people
kept hanging on at every level do you
think there's something psychologically
going on there that that didn't allow
them to let go
yeah you're going to get me in a lot of
trouble dave because we talk about this
a lot and the angriest emails i get are
on this topic so uh buckle up i suppose
you said something super interesting
which
nancy pelosi go be a grandma
and she kind of still sees herself as
this like 33 year old kind of like aids
crusader in west san francisco that his
eyebrows keep getting higher
yeah but do you know what i mean which
is like okay like you've had your chance
go look beyond yourself that's what a
grandma's all about right yeah like go
look about go look towards the next
generation and are you actually
preserving things that are beautiful
true and good for her it's kind of like
no i still have to have that one more
election cycle you don't understand
because that's when the real revolution
is going to happen
and so look i mean it's the tyranny of
the septogenarians and the octogenarians
and there's a lot of great people in the
70s and 80s category in our country it
just so happens none of them are in
leadership right now
right so
it just so happens that the cream that
whatever's risen to the top isn't the
best and so you kind of have a through
line of biden and schumer and pelosi
that have been in this schtick for 30 or
40 years literally
and they don't really care about the
damage they're leaving to the next
generation it's kind of like they want
to have their two to four years to rule
over the ashes and they're going to die
and i hate to be so morbid about it but
they're on the back nine of the back
nine they're on like hole 17 right and
so you got to start all of a sudden look
like who's the next group of people that
are going to be playing now
you know you've had eric weinstein on
your program before he talks about the
ego the embedded growth obligation i
think that's a really smart perspective
about how this is a generation that has
literally experienced nothing but
prosperity economically their entire
life and has gotten used to it and acts
as if that is something that is just
kind of baked in the human existence
things get better don't get in my way
but i think that
the entire way that we reacted to covid
kind of exposes all of this i think it
does so in bright and dramatic colors
which is it really is kind of the first
modern civilization that has willingly
sacrificed the young to placate the old
and there is no other way to describe it
i mean some people will reject the
premise but we went from shutting down
schools because it might hurt kids to
shutting down schools because they might
transmit a virus to grammar that's a
totally different moral argument by the
way totally different for the first
moral argument is like okay it might
kill young people i get that the next is
oh now they might get infected and they
might kill grandma i'm not into that
obviously i want to protect seniors but
that's a totally different argument
which is like okay we must inhibit your
development we must suppress your life
experience and your activities because
you might then hurt the generation that
does not have as many years left to live
and so yes i think an intergenerational
apology is necessary totally and i will
say that kind of that 35 to 54 year old
bracket is the i think
it is going to be in my opinion the
great swing to the right that no one
expected i think there's more red
pilling happening between ages 35 to 54
and there's a lot of boomers that are
really conservative and god bless them
for that and they continue to be but
there is kind of this question of like
the 42 year old mom that looks she's
like wait a second you know i wasn't
able to get the career advancement maybe
i wanted because i had to wait for
boomers to age out and now my kids have
to wear masks because a bunch of
septigenerians are worried about this
and i think that we're experiencing
the kind of the climax of generational
tension and we saw this i'll say one
final thing in this dave which is
this is nothing new this kind of immoral
behavior first manifested itself through
fiscal policy a generation that was
willing to borrow hundreds of billions
of dollars to add to the national debt
in 2009 2010 2011 2012 with no regard
for the fiscal health of future
generations is the same type of
generation that locks down seventh
graders and doesn't think anything of it
it's like you know that we just do that
around here okay like we'll put their
life on hold we'll steal their savings
we'll steal their purchasing power
because i'm important and i matter and i
think that really i think that betrays
the social contract i think
it goes directly against what it means
to be a patriotic citizen
you say 35 to 54 are going to be the red
child red pill generation it's like i'm
45. i know a little something about this
red pill situation right so it's like
i'm i'm with you man i i feel it um you
know you see those those pictures online
of you know stacy abrams unmasked in
front of the kids and hoco over in new
york smiling with the kids it's like
these kids are going to do some pretty
horrible things to old people one day
you can really feel it do you not not
just to talk about it at an idea level
but because you're around so many
college kids kids i mean they're young
adults uh through turning point have you
seen a real shift in their attitudes on
this stuff you know we go to the events
when i go to turnpoint events it's
always so positive and fun and all that
stuff but like have you seen
a difference in the way they're reacting
with the ideas or resentment or whatever
it might be
definitely on the center right for sure
our students are pushing back like crazy
all right we have
we have a list i was just going through
we have 35 schools that have staged
walkouts in the last 24 hours at turning
point usa over the mass mandates and we
support them 100 we're helping them with
pr support and times legal support all
that stuff because the mass mandates
have gone out of control but i will say
dave that the mass
propaganda dare i say mass formation
psycho psychosis
trying to get us both taken out man
yeah there we go well i figure this will
be on local so we know the owner they
want goodbye
so
yeah exactly but you know
that kind of mass propaganda campaign
has really worked on a lot of young
people and
it's kind of a great irony where and
this is a stereotype but the average
70 year old 60 or 70 year old right now
is far less concerned about covid than i
think the average 17 year old
and that's a stereotype that's like a
generalization i should say but there
has been a lot of induced fear
amongst high school and college kids
completely and totally unnecessarily and
there's a cost to pay for that it's
going to be a generation that is the
least free thinking generation absent
our intervention and trying to get them
their humanity back it's the most
medicated generation most suicidal
generation the most confused generation
the most directionalist generation but i
we're starting to see some pushback
against this and some hopefully writing
of that trajectory
but i don't think it's enough i don't
think that this is going to fix itself i
think that we need and i don't say this
lightly you know that i'm a small
government conservative guy but i think
that we need a collective intervention
to try to fix some of these trends that
have gone so awry i don't just think
that we're like oh well we shut
everything down for two years we
vaccinated kids didn't need it and put
masks on them they had no social
development they are not speaking the
way they should the iqs are stunted like
everything's going to kind of sort
itself out i'm not as convinced of that
i'm not i think there's some very
interesting bold robust entrepreneurial
and creative ideas that could probably
fix this but i'll be honest dave
there's been a little glimmer of hope
amongst some of the young people but
it's nowhere near the type of rebellion
that i would like to see it isn't i saw
far more activism and energy around
greta thundberg's the world is ending
climate change propaganda and far more
energy amongst the average high school
kid around floyda palooza than i did
around masked mandates vaccine mandates
or being locked down and not being able
to see their friends yeah and you're not
overstating this stuff i just read this
crazy study about what masks have done
to adolescent children who are now
having all sorts of delayed speech
literally the muscles in their mouths
are not developing the way that they are
supposed to because they don't move
their mouths and they don't talk enough
and and they can't see the mouth of the
teacher
so you can mimic it to speak probably i
mean it's really really crazy stuff um
what do you think of the pivot that
they're about to do we can see it
happening right in front of our eyes
they are the good guys they didn't want
to lock us down they're going to somehow
pin this on it was the republicans that
did it they're all just repeating the
stuff that uh char charlie kirk that
charlie kirk that ron desantis was
saying two years ago but charlie kirk
was probably saying some of it too i
mean we were saying the same thing do
you admire the pivot that they're about
to do that they're in the process of
doing right now
do i admire it no i think it's good for
the country yeah it's better now than 10
years from now sure good terrific uh but
i mean look i i don't say this slightly
there needs to be justice people need to
go to jail for what they did there needs
to be some sort of mass firing campaign
decredentialing campaign none of that's
probably gonna happen i'll be very
honest yeah but what would that really
look like because i i've kind of thought
about it like i do think some of these
people probably in a really sane society
that would grapple with this prop
properly some of these people would end
up in jail like literally in jail and
and but i don't know what does that
really look like we're gonna have a
nuremberg for coverage i would love
nuremberg but i mean some people say
that's radical but i mean there is i
think a lot of the tenants have no
there's the media matters clip for today
well no i mean we've done entire shows
on nuremberg but yeah sure they could
pick it up and run with it but that's
probably not going to happen i try to
live in the land of reality um i don't
think that's going to happen anytime
soon what i would like to see though
happen dave is a legitimate public
policy and legislative campaign around
medical autonomy around medical freedom
um and i think we there's a lot of
answers we yet we still do not have uh
we do not have answers around the money
flow from a lot of these pharmaceutical
companies to politicians or their
campaigns we do not have answers as to
why early treatments were suppressed
we've been a very outspoken program on
ivermectin hydroxychloroquine
azithromycin melatonin aspirin
monoclonal antibodies intravenous
therapy vitamin d levels i think it's
one of the great injustices of my life
the fact that most americans were not
properly exposed to those things but
don't worry we're subsidizing crack
cocaine pipes for people you know in san
francisco all the while the controlled
substance our government cares about is
the perfectly safe and probably very
very effective ivermectin it's it's dude
biden sent me three crack pipes i only
need one you want me to send you one is
that i i wouldn't know what to do with
it to be very honest so
um haven't exactly
ventured into that domain of human
existence so um yeah
yeah he'd give me lip balm in case my
lips get too chapped while smoking crack
on the you know in in fisherman's wharf
in san francisco but yeah look what
would justice look like i don't know but
we definitely need some action right we
need legislative changes we also i think
just from a more constitutional
perspective we have to make sure the
emergency use powers are never used
again by these governors and mayors and
that might be wishful thinking but i
think in some red states they were used
and abused way too much i think these
legislatures have to step up and look if
you want to shut down a state go to the
legislative process i totally i would
say that's fine if like you can get the
ohio state house and state senate to
shut down a state for 30 days i actually
think that's okay i think that the
courts might knock it down here and
there but just like the fact that a
governor can just sign a piece of paper
and shut down bars and schools that's i
think that's a usurpation of what the
constitution especially in a state-based
level and definitely a federal level is
supposed to be able to do i'll give you
another example the fact that joe biden
can just sign a piece of paper and say
you have to wear a mask on an airplane
go through the legislative process so
those are some remedies for sure that we
have to do that i think could slow down
kind of this indulgence of you know kind
of autocratic and tyrannical behavior
we've seen but we're not going to get
the justice that i would want to see
dave i think that any doctor that
interfered with a patient trying to get
ivermectin or hydroxychloroquine needs
to be held criminally accountable and i
don't say that lightly and dave you get
a lot of emails i get a ton of emails i
have hundreds of emails of people that
have relatives that died in the hospital
and they were trying to give them these
life-saving drugs and the hospital says
oh those drugs might kill them and then
they die and so it's like what we're
dealing from already the potential of we
know death is in the cards so why
wouldn't you try some of the more you
know let's say you know
censored
treatments and so i think there needs to
be adjusted with that and the hospital's
going to be held accountable but just
kind of managing expectations that's
probably not going to happen
but um the last thing you said do i
admire it no i don't admire why are they
doing it well the science has not
changed
no matter what you know doctor when says
changed because it's changed
yeah i mean look and this is the thing
is that trust the science trust the
science we did a whole podcast on this
that i think it was really well received
one of the best podcasts we've done in a
while as far as like response which is
that they conflate two things right so
they conflate things that we would call
the natural law like force equals mass
times acceleration the irrefutable
tenants of western science right the
inquiry into the natural world second
law of thermodynamics the inevitable law
of decay
and they conflate that with conjecture
and hypothesis right so they put that
all into kind of the same term as if if
you challenge wearing three masks while
you shower you're somehow at war with
copernicus
right and like the average engineer who
works at ford right is like well you
know i'm trading the sciences i don't
ever want to question that when in
reality
they had that which is we know and that
which we think we know and they were
never honest enough to separate those
two things charlie you're blowing my
mind right now i got to write this down
are you telling me
that a squared plus b squared equals c
squared is more valid
than when you're at a restaurant you can
walk in without a mask and when you or
when you have a mask and you walk in and
you can take it off and you sit is that
what you're telling me here
i'm telling that you know i know you
might really blow your audience's mind
that the things we know
in the western scientific tradition that
have been true that really proven to be
the laws of nature in nature's god which
thomas jefferson brilliantly wrote in
the declaration is far better science
than
vaccinating a six six month old with a
vaccine against a virus that isn't going
to harm them significantly anyway or
let's just think of all this the
scientific calisthenics that we've heard
in just the last couple weeks was it
gavin eric garcetti said he held his
breath when he uh
took a picture at sofi stadium or gavin
newsom he said well i just took a
picture i put the mask back on i mean
and just the or dr vivek murphy who said
you have to wear masks at home around
your children that was in the last
couple of months
and we we know the science is totally
insane i mean you take the mask mandate
on planes for example it's right it's
the only virus in the history of
communicable diseases that does not come
out as soon as the beverage cart comes
out it stops
it's so scared of the hot hot coffee and
the sanitized coke bot you know coke
cans that it stops all transmission but
from going from new york to la for a
year and a half of the pandemic you
could not go eat indoors but if you
wanted to go eat indoors just go board
american airlines at jfk and fly to lax
we all folded we all kind of folded you
know i said to my guys it's like i'm i'm
doing just fine i'm not complaining
about life but my goal
after these last two years is to become
so rich i never have to fly commercial
again because i flew private twice for
the first time ever in this past year
and the they've made the flying
experience even though yes you can take
off your mask to drink your coffee and
eat your small chicken uh it just
ain't right what they're doing but do
you think the federal mass mandate i
mean
i haven't heard any talk about they're
gonna stop it on airplanes and we've got
idiots like uh swalwell pushing for
pushing it forever
do i i don't slept with the chinese spy
but that's a whole other thing that i
mean yeah i don't know if he did it on a
plane or not that would be a very
interesting uh chapter two of the
fanfang diaries as long as he had his
mask on yeah that's right i mean that's
correct so do i think the federal mass
mandate will be lifted no and you
actually you make a really important
point which is because the people in
charge aren't affected by it but biden
doesn't fly commercial flies air force
one yep i mean
but he always puts his mask on right
before he gets off air force one i
always love that when it's like oh yeah
yeah you guys have been wearing it on
the helicopter right an air force one
okay and it's covered theater but this
this goes to a deeper point that the
founding fathers warned us against and
the the and the more we kind of dwell
and we marinate and ruminate on the
brilliance and the wisdom of the
founding fathers we realize they saw a
lot of this coming which i think in
federalist 51 or one of those associates
madison warned
what would happen if the group of rulers
are exempt from the laws that they push
upon the citizenry and that's why
congress technically can't pass laws
that they are immune from they found
carve outs in ways to do that but the
federal mass man on airplanes is a
perfect example of this which is a vast
majority of the members of congress and
especially people financing the members
of congress they're totally unaffected
by it and their kids go to private
schools where there are no mask mandates
and they fly on private jets where
there's no mass mandates and yeah look
governor mussolini married into the
siebel family i don't know the last time
he flew commercial right he's flying
around probably on a gulf stream or a
learjet or whatever and i guarantee you
the family's not masking you know when
they hit 15 000 or 20 000 feet no
they're having a great time and they're
laughing about it and charlie they spent
they spent 200 grand on a one-week
vacation in cabo about three months ago
right the same week he extended his
emergency powers i don't live there
anymore by the way very exciting can't
you tell yeah you're happier you're
paying more taxes right you've become
more conservative which is just
delightful
um but yeah it's
and we call it hypocrisy it's not it's
hierarchy dave it's not hypocrisy it's i
am better than you i'm gonna crush you
and i don't care
yeah he's he's a bad he's a bad dude but
all right i know we can go on this stuff
forever but let's let's link some of
this uh to the big tech stuff that you
and i have been talking about forever
uh and as you said we're both involved
in the rumble situation you you were
sort of early on with the rumble team
obviously locals merged with rumble
there's a lot going on there um do you
honestly think we have a chance i mean
even just uh in the last couple days
look we put our best foot forward we
made this offer to joe rogan
he may not take it but we felt it was
the best thing we could do to defend our
principles
and fight for what we believe in we
shall see um you know we're fighting on
every front the payment processor front
the aws front the algorithm front but do
you think we can really do it we don't
have a choice
we have to win all right we have to get
this right or else everything we love
falls apart
i have been so encouraged though just in
the last 12 months dave
how much momentum there is behind this
kind of new technology space from locals
which is terrific which is a way to
bypass the patreon gatekeepers to the
content creators that have gone all in
on rumble you our program dan bongino
dinesh d'souza russell brand tulsi
gabbard you know freedom loving liberty
loving people all across the spectrum
but do believe that big tech tyranny is
an existential threat i thought the
offer to rogan was really brilliant i
don't know rogan i've met him once i
think it would be really smart of him
personally to take the rumble deal
because they are not going to stop this
is that this
censorship hit job train he says oh
spotify stood by me i don't think so
they're removing episodes and putting
disclaimers you and i are way too
cynical for that dave we've been through
this entire program many times and maybe
a couple years ago we might have said
that but uh
and look it's definitely the rumble was
really smart to offer the 100 million
dollars because it made it legit and
i don't we'll see if we'll see what
rogan ends up doing right i mean he's
signaled towards spotify or whatever but
the point is that it wasn't totally
laughed off dave and that shows how real
rumble is
right that shows that
we we can win this so to answer your
question on the probability argument i
first made a moral argument we have to
win this we have to do this i think
rumble's going to be a 20 or 30 or 40
billion dollar company i'm confident of
that because there is a center right of
the planet not just the country that is
desiring a platform that actually allows
voices to speak their mind and not be
taken off and not have these sort of
woke gatekeepers but look they're going
to be institutional challenges but to
you know i know we keep talking about
rumble but they're not you know not
alone there's other people in playing
but rumble's definitely the most
sophisticated i think best funded and
most momentum
i think that i think that it's ahead of
schedule and i think that there's going
to be start i think there's some chatter
already in silicon valley of what are we
going to do about these rumble guys well
you can't shut off their servers right
you could probably go after after their
advertisers for now but then you got
locals which is hundreds of thousands of
grassroots people supporting people via
patreon which is going to be incredibly
effective to be able to kind of have the
super chat feature of videos which is a
huge revenue source for google there'll
be institutional ads that will always go
behind rumble that are on the center
right and so
what else do they kind of have in the
tickler file to try to go after rumble
okay they're going to try to go after
the ad network they're going to try to
go after new york times washington post
you're platforming hateful people yeah
but when you start to have a roster of
dave rubin charlie kirk you know daily
wire is coming online is what i'm
hearing you have dan bongino and others
all of a sudden you're like yeah okay
we're going to link arms and we've
created technato
and we have article six and you attack
one tech nato you didn't just come up
with that did you you've used that one
before come on never said it out loud
but i have wrote it i have a whole as i
have a whole
pamphlet of kind of one-liners but you
can use it nato and tech nato it's
article 5 or article 6 of nato which is
attack on one of us is attacked on all
of us
right and to kind of tie in the whole
ukrainian thing that's why ukraine and
nato is such a controversial thing it's
like putin crosses the line it's the
same as invading paris or london and
it's like okay you go after dave rubin
then you have to deal with all of us and
our combined power and our combined
followers
and
i'm starting to see that solidarity and
guess what that word solidarity is
something that we freedom loving people
don't do well but when we do it we win
it's not in our blood we're all
entrepreneurs or individuals we think we
could do things better than each other
right we're competitors you know we'll
go out to dinner with one another and
they'll be like yeah i kind of like that
idea and that like whatever but that's
that's what's beautiful about markets
but now we're at war and we need
solidarity and we need alliances so i
think we got a chance to win
i like that every time i'm on your show
when i say something clever you always
say to me i'm stealing that but i'm
gonna credit you
for this technado you got it you know
that's the difference that's the
difference between us right
attribution
but but do you see
okay so let's say we build this stuff
and it's all great and i and you yes we
are working real hard and there's a lot
of questions but there's a lot of
answers as well so we start building all
that we know that the the trends where
people are moving are going very heavily
you know for to freedom-loving places
nobody's moving to blue states right now
i think california lost almost 400 000
people last year first now loss of
population ever
as these things continue to go i mean
what keeps us the united states if we've
just got our own products and we've got
our own states and they've got their
products and their states
where are we united
well we aren't and you're right and so
just kind of reinforce the point though
you know netflix is down facebook is
down california is down florida is up
texas up rumble is up right
so look i've said this for quite some
time i think we're living through a slow
motion secession movement and the act of
secession is happening on united
airlines every day in the non-stop
flight from
los angeles to orlando or from los
angeles to miami it's a movement of
secession and it's not it's not a one
that breaks the country apart
immediately
but they're starting to say out loud
what i have feared and it's mostly pop
icon people you know uh sarah silverman
or that guy from hellboy whatever his
name is
oh that nut bag ron peron yeah whatever
and they're saying it out loud i don't
want to live in the country with you you
don't want to live with me let's go our
separate ways and a very provocative but
honest thought exercise for your
audience and for all of us to kind of
dwell over which is what do i charlie
kirk who live in phoenix what do i have
in common with a san francisco woke
activist that's 24 years old that just
graduated from uc berkeley i believe
america's awesome they believe america
is awful
i believe
in basic natural rights they believe in
collective and tribal rights i believe
in free speech they believe in power
i believe that we should have borders
they don't believe in borders and i
could go through the whole checkpoint
the checklist the only thing that we
have in common is the dollar bill that
we're trading
it's literally the whole project is
basically hinging on a currency and that
is not an over exaggeration you don't
have a shared story you don't have
shared values you don't have a shared
future you don't have a shared policy
prescriptions everything is quote
unquote politicized and divided and so
you know we've
we've kind of dwelled in this field to
the great you know the great cost of
being written up in media matters which
is a wonderful thing to happen they're
like pr expert they love you over there
they like you more than me with all the
pieces they do it's great they write up
what you say and it's right there and
then you could share it like hey look
but look it's we are we are right on on
the hinge we're right on the edge of a
national divorce now i have a contrarian
view on this which is i actually think
the sooner we built the build the
parallel economy and we have these other
mediums i actually think it de-escalates
the chance for a national divorce i
think it's the exact opposite
yeah i like that actually it's kind of
like all right you do you we do us like
maybe we can have like a five year
cooling off period before we actually
sign the divorce papers right
and i i don't think i think the more
that we live under their tyranny you're
gonna see real radicalism rise up that i
hate and you hate right where people are
starting to talk about things that i
don't i don't want the country to break
up i think it's an awful thing it's my
home it's your home i don't want to have
to show a passport when i go to lax it's
like i want that to be my fellow
countrymen i don't know if they believe
that um i think that they want to
i i think there's there's two there's
two thoughts on this right which is
most of the leftist rulers will reject a
national divorce because they want the
whole enchilada right in every county
they want every inch and they want us to
live in their tyranny like they are up
at night
really angry that some baptist preacher
in enid oklahoma he's not like perfectly
in alignment with like every single one
of their world views right like that
that really bothers them where it's like
as a conservative like i don't really
care about some guy in brooklyn that
hates me like okay whatever it's like so
who's the actual liberal in this
equation right like who's the live and
let live guy right it's like is it the
baptist preacher or the conservative in
phoenix or is it like the person in
brooklyn that's really angry that
someone disagrees with them in like
central iowa but you know that's part of
it but i think that
so those are the kind of the imperial
democrats right they want to take over
territory it's like we are not going to
stop till everyone succumbs to our
agenda and then the other side of it
though are like the sarah silverman ron
perlman types which they're actually
being more humble and honest i have to
say that i have way more respect for
people that are like let's just break up
and not fight
and that's actually a better
that's a better starting point than like
we're going to take over kansas like
well hold on a second like probably not
gonna that's not in the cards does that
make sense
yeah but can i put a fly in that
ointment on the second one for you which
is they're saying let's break up and
just that's it but they'll never let
that be i think you you would agree with
that right if we give them the breakup
that they want sarah silverman guess
what she wants
it's like she'll never stop she's not
going to stop as florida flourishes as
arizona flourishes and texas flourishes
and as their places
you know just crumble they're not gonna
stop now they're gonna want what we got
so the second one might be more honest
um but it's not i don't think it's fully
thought through no it's not thought
through and look there's and i this is
not exaggerated there's a thousand
externalities that i don't have answers
for military water rights ports of entry
right like who gets rights to minerals
how do you travel back and forth how do
you divide the citizenship what if you
don't want to live there i mean it's
like again we have
if we actually put our heads together
there's enough mature people that could
probably figure this out but if we're
dealing with chuck schumer like i don't
know like that's probably not going to
go well do you know what i mean he's
like no no no actually i want
marshallton iowa like
you can't have right
and so yeah that's why i
i and you we want to heal this land
we want this to work we want this
republic to stay together
i don't think there is a manageable exit
from this and i don't i would rather
solve this with ballots than bullets as
abraham lincoln said and i i don't want
this to go to conflict i'm afraid it's
trending that way and the the media
always says like oh charlie thinks the
civil war is coming first so i never use
that term but when i say conflict i
don't think that's out of the cards
i want it to happen but you can only
raise the temperature in the room so
much before you kind of provoke a
kinetic response and so i actually think
the parallel economy is going to be an
unintended pressure release valve for
liberty loving people across the country
which is like okay
now i at least have a place i can watch
videos like now i have a place i can
bank
right now i have a place i can get a
mortgage
and i think that's going to hopefully
bring the temperature down in the room
despite the you know the best wishes the
other side that seems like it seems like
they want conflict which is a whole
different conversation for different
time it seems like they want us to punch
first and then they could justify the
security state apparatus behind it
now this concept of of building the
parallel economy purely to keep it
together is actually interesting because
most people think of it as oh that
accelerates the separation because then
we can just go our separate ways but i
like this i like this release valve idea
kirk you got one today thank you very
impressive thank you
you got it all right now let me get you
in some real trouble okay
because everybody is looking to the
midterms and there's this feeling that
there's going to be this red wave
although as i said we're seeing the
pivot happen in real time and you can
also feel the media trying to link
january 6 to somehow the truckers and
that were exporting a worldwide
insurrection and all of this nonsense
but i want to ask you this well a i
guess give me a little bit of your take
on what you think is going to happen in
the midterms and are there areas we
could focus in to make sure that we get
a nice result but b you know everyone's
looking at the 2024 situation i want to
desantis to stay the governor of florida
that's what i want i think the state you
live in is way more important i think
he's only been in one term so far he's
done a heck of a job i i just think
that's more important than the
presidency believe it or not although
obviously it is important
do you as a guy that at least part-time
lives in florida or is there a lot
do you like that idea uh do you think he
should run where does trump fall out
what do you know on the inside the whole
damn thing charlie i'll start with the
midterms i think republicans are going
to do well i'm worried that we're not
going to do nearly as well as we should
uh every single indicator shows
republicans are going to take back the
house senate is a little bit up for
grabs this should be a 60 or 70 year
seat majority for the house
representatives which is enough where
you could hold on to that for at least
two or three more cycles
um
so i don't know it remains to be seen
democrats are going to try to correct a
couple things you could start to see
that already they're having obama come
in and try to tell them to not be so
radical out loud he's really good at
kind of saying like right he does it on
the video stop telling the truth right
like that that's kind of his whole deal
to try to tell people to you know that
are running for office to just
camouflage the radicalism right just
tell people what they want to hear
so i think that they're gonna i think
they're to get their parade in order
shortly that's my warning to republicans
i still think we're going to do very
very well
um especially in some of these senate
races like arizona and georgia i think
it will be a 7 to 10 point swing on top
of what things naturally are i'm afraid
i'll reinforce a point i said earlier i
think it will be a misleading indicator
of the health of the republican party
because of how bad the democrats are
this will be a massive indictment of the
woke and the democrats and the insane
and the coveted lockdowns where people
are just looking for some way that they
can just like what can i vote for that
isn't them i think virginia was an
example of that i think the incredibly
unexpected airtight race in new jersey
was an example of that i think a
republican winning the city attorney's
race in seattle was an example of that
that's all back in november but it's
important to remind people of that so
that that's one thing i'm happy to go
more into that it's still
it's too early to kind of make
predictions on like seat majorities but
i am not seeing from republicans what i
really want which is a newt gingrich
style contract with america promises
clear and concise here's what we're
going to do and it's not just you know
free trade and giving china what they
want and a mass amnesty plan and lower
taxes and socialism is bad enough right
i think voters want more than that and i
think they want honesty so on the trump
thing in 2024 he is going to run every
single indication points towards that i
think actually trump will benefit from a
primary challenge
um i think that if he actually has to
run against somebody who isn't a joke i
actually think that would really be good
for him i think that's one of the things
that made him such a powerful general
election candidate in 2016 because he
had some of the most amazing
metaphorical political crossfit training
one could have i mean he ran up against
like 29 000 people right it was like 16.
but it was like from every direction
right it was like boom scott walker and
boom ben carson was like jeb bush and
ted cruz he was like non-stop by the
time he had run against hillary he's
like i ran against 16 people this is
nothing so i think that i'm not trying
to encourage someone to run against him
i would rather see him obviously go
unopposed if that's necessary it's
probably better for him in the sense of
you know not having to spend as much
money but i actually think kind of
shaking off kind of some of the dust and
getting back into the metaphorical ring
could be really really good for him um
as far as desantis goes i think he's
unbelievable i think he's the greatest
governor of the last 10 or 20 or 30 i
can't think of a better governor ron
desantis has done everything right and
everything issue that matters to me from
vaccine mandates to opening up florida
to being strong on crime across the
board he's been phenomenal i think
someone like desantis or it could be him
is the future of the republican party i
truly do uh but trump's going to run and
that's going to be a challenge for a lot
of people i think that once you win one
presidential election uh you deserve a
chance to run again i really do uh in
2020 there were massive irregularities
happy to get into all the kind of voter
fraud conversation if you want i think
dinesh d'souza's new film is
extraordinary in what it uh looks into
and the evidence is very very compelling
i think some of that could be sure
i think trump could win again and look i
think that there's positives and
negatives to him running again the
positives are he was a terrific
president he was tremendous we know what
we're getting he has a base unlike
anything we've ever seen he'll raise a
bunch of money and small dollar
donations he'll work his tail off
and i think that he also has a record to
run on in contrast to this current
absolute dumpster fire that we are
seeing in real time and also make no
mistake i don't think people are really
looking forward to having another
democrat president after four years if
we had i want people to think about this
if we had a parliamentary system and
there was right now a national vote of
no confidence confidence against joe
biden he'd get run out of there
immediately now we don't have that type
of system right we just don't um but if
the election were held today donald
trump would just clobber him and every
like he would win like 40 states i think
he would win new hampshire he'd win
nevada
and so look i also think though that
trump has to have he has to make some
adjustments going in 2024. if you're
running up against a self-destructive
candidate do not get in the way of your
enemy defeating himself i think that was
something that's a great learning lesson
from 2020 and i think 2016 trump where
he was big bold ambitious and he was
willing to capture the imagination of
the american people i think he has to
play a little bit more into that
it's hard when you're an incumbent to do
that i get it but 2016 trump he made
people dream he really pushed the
boundaries of what a political candidate
is allowed to talk about i think he
could recapture that in a very very
compelling way in 2024
charlie kirk
future political consultant yeah it's
been a pleasure talking to you my friend
i will see you probably in i sense it
will be on the west coast of florida
what do you think west coast of florida
is the place to be i my place in florida
will not be disclosed but it's not too
far from rumble's headquarters the
heartbeat
of the response to the silicon valley
tyranny so honored dave thank you
and uh check out my locals everybody
it's gonna be great
it's charliekirk.locals.com right that's
right that's correct
see you brother see you soon thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell